I'm thrilled to welcome to the program
today dr. patch Adams who is a
world-renowned doctor clown and activist
who believes that the health and
diseases of individuals really can't be
separated from the health and diseases
of their communities of their country of
the world he's also director of the
ghazan tight Institute which is a
nonprofit organization focused on
healing the financial and social traumas
of our for-profit health care system dr.
Adams it's so great to have you on I
really appreciate it
can we call me patch yes create
hierarchy let's do it let's do it patch
so listen there the conversation around
how care is delivered to people has been
so front and center in the current
Democratic presidential primary it's
been a front and center topic since the
United States adopted Obama care about
ten years ago where do you think the
conversation around this issue is just
completely missing the mark well I think
most of the conversation is around
trying to do something with the problems
rather than giving a great vision our
work has been knowing the problems and
creating a great vision and when you
think about that vision does it line up
with the system that any country around
the world currently has no it doesn't
know can you say more about that why not
what is missing from the systems around
the world can I describe what we're
doing yes okay I entered medical school
in 1967 because I thought doctoring was
a love job for men I quickly within a
month found out that there was nothing I
liked about the system that I was
hearing about and seeing in the
hospitals most doctors were rude and
arrogant and
hierarchical and there wasn't any fun or
love or these kinds of things in a
hospital setting it was frenetic and
yeah and so I am happy to say I am a
nerd so I didn't have to study much in
medical school I spent my time deciding
what kind of health system I would like
and I did that and when I graduated
nobody gave me a hospital I guess
they're expensive so I did what people
in the 60s did 20 of us moved into a six
bedroom house and said we were a
hospital open 24/7 and in the 12 years
we operated we had about 500 to a
thousand people in our home each month
with five 250 overnight guests a night
in a six bedroom house that already had
20 adults and its children living there
so let's say it was intimate yes and I
wanted a hospital setting that was happy
funny loving cooperative creative and
thoughtful that that's a climate for
good health and a climate for non Berna
because so often in wanting to change
the healthcare system it's more about
helping the patient's get what they need
rather than the staff gets what they
need so all of this time I'm in the 50th
year of fundraising for a project I
thought would take four to find the
funding because our design eliminated
90% of the cost of care that's what I
want to focus in on can you talk about
how ninety you know people talk about we
can eliminate 3% with some bureaucratic
simplification we can look at
unnecessary testing to get another 5%
how do you achieve a 90% reduction in
cost well put on your seat though yes
okay so
we have 327 acres in Pocahontas County
West Virginia the poorest state for
health care in the u.s. yes we want to
build a 40 bed primary care rural
community hospital on that land all of
the permanent staff would live there as
a communal eco village I'm thinking a
hundred and twenty permanent staff and
that everyone from the cleaning person
to the surgeon would make the same
salary hold your seat three hundred
dollars a month okay
the hospital will be an extensive
permaculture farm and artist colony and
I feel that we with that design we we
won't accept health insurance no one
will have to fill out any of those forms
and we'll we'll practice medicine an
interesting addition is that we we found
in the 12 years we were practice even
though we often did it illegally at the
time that acupuncture homeopathy
naturopathy area of a decanter Pacific
healing all had a role in medicine the
only one that was non allopathic that
was legal in my state was chiropractic
and we found all of them were great
additions to what we learned that's
interesting so you're most physicians
tend to take the view that on something
like homeopathy there there may well be
some kind of placebo benefit but for
example many homeopathic the substances
have no active ingredients and thus they
don't really do anything you as a
physician take a different approach well
when I try to check out a healing
approach I asked the healers that do it
okay so for faith healing
if you don't think faith-healing has any
effect don't do it or or at least don't
push it homeopathy which is all over the
world and I've seen it do great things
hmm the week of the the homeopathic
remedy often the stronger which goes
against everything we were taught but
one could question the value for example
in mental illness in 50 years of
practice I never disliked a patient
enough to give a psychiatric diagnosis
or a psychiatric medication okay and so
there are lots of points of view out
there
I mean acupuncture if I rub this point
here and it got rid of 80% of the
headaches in 48 years of rubbing that
point on both sides
and how does rubbing a point in the hand
affect a headache in an authentic
medicine it would be called quackery
rights so the concept would be all the
doctors get paid 300 bucks a month
$3,600 for the year that drastically
reduces all of the staff yea doctors
included everybody gets $3,600 for the
year yeah you do
Ayurvedic as well as homeopathic
medicine and this cuts costs by ninety
percent now will you be fully staffed in
terms of if somebody needs you know of a
heart-related and aortic valve
replacement will you be able to do
something like that
well that's why I said primary care ah
good okay so there are heart surgeries
that are primary care there are that are
tertiary care and so if if the doctor at
the surgeons we have feel comfortable
we'll do it and where do you think that
you will find the medical staff that is
interested in
in that salary of $3,600 a year
well a bonus of being in the 50th year
rather than the first year and adding to
that fame when we closed our doors in 83
within a year I felt a real intense
absence of care I need to care I'm one
of those people and I didn't have a
hospital and so I decide I can't go and
work in a regular hospital that that
would hurt me and so I did I added two
kinds of care what was Clown trips and
I've done clowned trips all over the
world in fact the last Russia trip that
we had had eight doctors and five nurses
because they wanted to put more humor in
their practice and the other thing I did
was answer mail so in these years I've
answered 400,000 letters from a hundred
and thirty nine countries well from all
over the world
I hear discontent in medical doctors and
in nurses that hate what they're doing
they hate the context they the hospitals
are unhappy they're miserable and this
is pretty well known in this country as
well and so you know one can decide that
rich has many meanings rich is good
friends hmm rich is doing exactly what
you want in the way that you want yes
rich is having good health are you
getting what I'm saying absolutely on
our land there are three waterfalls a
four acre lake black bear beaver otter
deer wild turkey it's it's a natural
paradise and you get to practice
medicine so as a family doctor I like my
initial interview with an adult to be 3
or 4 hours long because we're
complicated well and I want to
have so much time that we fall in love
with each other that the friendship
between health professional and patient
can often be the medicine they need
right and Pat you were portrayed by the
late Robin Williams in the film patch
Adams which is of course based based on
your life and your views on medicine
that that you've told us a little bit
about here how did you feel about that
portrayal do you feel that it was an
accurate portrayal of you well I loved
Robin his personality though he was much
more introverted than I he he was a
wonderful playmate and he cares so the
movie wanted to sell tickets they
promised to build us and did not and I
mean they changed what they wanted to
change so the real person murdered was
not my girlfriend but my closest male
friend in medical school that was the
thing I disliked the most the creative
liberties they took right they they
didn't want to change the future of
healthcare they wanted to sell a Robin
Williams movie and they did didn't they
oh it was a huge seller yeah I I spanked
their bottom that they did not build our
hospital so explain that they had made
an intimation that they would support
your hospital with some of the proceeds
build it they said we'll build the
hospital well you know Fame is a
nightmare and so I needed something and
by that time enough time had passed
where I wanted a hospital and I knew
that they would make enough to be rich
themselves and I wanted to hide it I
didn't want the money
I wanted a hospital and it did not
materialize right Wow well well yes yah
go ahead I asked
they didn't answer the letters they
didn't respond to that Wow that is that
is an incredible story
well dr. Patz yeah are you 90% of the
people who have said patch I'm gonna
send you some money didn't do it either
why do you think that is I think that's
the world we live in a sad reality you
know I've never been discouraged it's
really fun to work for something
beautiful they're great members of the
team and I'm having fun along the way
I've climbed at 10,000 deathbeds in
Trinidad I clown for five men who were
hung the next morning for capital crimes
or loved it because of our work groups
of clowns are going in hospitals in a
hundred and forty countries to try the
up the vibe I guess and so I'm not going
oh darn we haven't built right the
hospital may not have materialized but
so many other things have correct and
we're not the only people trying to
change health care delivery and and yet
it hasn't been changing much right
that's for sure that's for sure
listen dr. patch Adams it's been such a
pleasure speaking with you and you
sharing a little bit about your life and
what you've done I encourage my audience
to learn more about what you're doing
including at the gesundheit Institute
and I so appreciate your time today